et les 8h14 votre invité ce matin sonia
mabrouk et le haut commissaire au plan
effectivement bienvenue sur europe 1 et
bonjour françois bayrou bonjour
également président du modem mais
d'abord haut commissaire au plan et dont
on parle de ce pnr de poux nerfs de pau
toujours des choses et son temps nous
n'oublions pas nous en parlerons mais
d'abord dans le plan d'investissement de
30 milliards annoncés hier par le
président lui nucléaire occupe une place
de choix avec la construction à venir de
minicentrale comment vous expliquez
monsieur bayrou ce revirement plutôt
cette conversion pragmatisme de la part
du chef de l'état bon j'étais déjà venu
à votre micro pour présenter la note que
nous avions faite sur la production
d'électricité en france avec une
question toute simple
nous nous sommes engagés et tout le
monde affirme vouloir
produire de l'électricité sans émissions
de gaz à effet de serre si on veut pas
émettre des moules de gaz à effet de
serre il n'ya que deux solutions
possibles le renouvelable les éoliennes
et vous savez que ça fait des polémiques
le photovoltaïque etc sont des milliers
d'hectares qu'il faudrait geler sous les
panneaux photovoltaïques mais il faut le
faire il faut développer le renouvelable
simplement
le renouvelable comme vous savez est
intermittent ya pas toujours du soleil a
pas toujours du vent alors que faire
lorsque le courant électrique qui vient
du soleil et du vent est absent eh bien
il faut ce qu'on appelle de
l'électricité pilotable qu'on peut
injecter dans le réseau et c'est
électricité il y en a que deux sortes
tout petit enfin assez petite
hydroélectricité où le nucléaire si on
ne veut pas émettre de gaza c'est
pourquoi cette constance on n'ait pas
pensé avant est ce que c'est le fait
qu'on soit six mois de la présidentielle
que c'est le fait que ça gronde sur les
factures qui explose ça faciliter la
relance du nucléaire par le président
non je crois que c'est la prise de
conscience qu'il porte depuis longtemps
que face au défi climatique
il faut des solutions qui soient des
solutions réelles concrètes et
utilisable et pas des voeux pieux
autrement on manque notre objectif vous
savez que la france et par chance le
pays
du monde sans doute ou en tout cas
à part deux ou trois pays scandinaves
c'est le pays du monde qui émet le moins
de gaz à effet de serre pour fabriquer
son électricité dix fois moins que
l'allemagne qui a abandonné le nucléaire
pour faire du charbon et le charbon n'y
a pas plus polluant que le charbon est
donc cette c'est cette prise de
conscience là ce que souhaitait le
tardive nous sommes à quelques mois de
la fin du quinquennat monsieur vers vous
avez publié une note d'ailleurs très
intéressante que nous avons eu
l'occasion on l'a détaillé ici même
électricité le devoir de lucidité vous
estimez avoir pesé dans le choix des
manuels macron bron je pense que oui en
tout cas tout ce qui
permet de rouvrir un débat qu'on croyait
fermer il ya un an à ce micro vous
auriez dit écoutez franchement le
nucléaire c'est plus à la mode c'est
bien moi je leur ai pas dit mais vous le
disais dans la majorité c'est pour ça
que on s'étonne que ce resserrement
partout non c'est pas pour moi ce n'est
pas un revirement c'est une prise de
conscience et c'est une prise de
conscience commandé par les engagements
que nous avons pris que la france a pris
d'être un pays où le pays leader dans la
transition énergétique pour défendre le
climat faut il faut mesurer que si nous
ne si nous continuons comme ça ce qui
est en train de se passer dans beaucoup
de pays européens
ils se prétendent vertueux et ils
sortent du nucléaire parce que ça fait
plaisir à une partie de leurs opinions
mais il remplace le nucléaire qui n'émet
pas de gaz à effet de serre 0 ils le
remplacent par du charbon c'est à dire
le pire du pire de ce qu'on peut faire
en utilisation d'accord mais monsieur
bayrou est ce que le président on veut
comprendre ce matin à ce que le
président qui à fermer fessenheim certes
dans la continuité de françois hollande
est ce que le président qui a nommé
nicolas hulot antinucléaires notoire est
ce que le président qui a nommé barbara
pompili ministre de la transition qui a
dit ceci un jour on peut se passer du
nucléaire est ce que ce présent est
vraiment crédible en chantre du
nucléaire nomme d'abord en chantre vous
présentez les choses de manière un peu
tendancieuse
il n'y aura pas de responsables français
quel que soit son nom et quelle que soit
sa fonction qui
proposera de respecter les engagements
que la france a pris de ne plus émettre
de gaz à effet de serre en fabriquant de
l'électricité s'il ne prend pas en
compte la nécessité de produire de
l'électricité regarder il n'y a pas que
il n'ya pas que la production via la
consommation bien sûr ce que tout le
monde dit ce que toutes les
organisations de protection de
l'environnement disent c'est qu'il va
falloir avoir un recours multiplier à
l'électricité
électrification de la mobilité commander
c'est à dire des voitures ni bus
des poids lourds et puis électrification
des usages à la maison chauffage tous
les usages électriques tout le monde dit
il faut maintenant que multiplier
l'électricité nome qui va produire bien
alors est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
parce que le président françois bayrou a
parlé de ces petits réacteurs ces mini
centrale & small modulant reactors ce
n'est pas pour demain valérie pécresse
ou eric zemmour vont beaucoup plus loin
en parlant de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires les opm qu'il faut construire
emmanuel macron n'a même pas prononcer
le mot hier pour noir il a dit une
phrase il faut il faut écouter
attentivement vous avez été attentif et
oui
il a dit une phrase il a dit il y aura
d'autres décisions à prendre dans les
mois qui viennent à la et vous vous les
connaissez de ce point de vue là je n'ai
aucun doute mois qu'il va falloir
investir prendre la décision d'investir
puissamment dans le renouvellement du
parc de centrales électriques nucléaires
ans la livraison de le père de
flamanville se dire qu'il faut
construire nouveau au père avant cette
plage pendant que ces questions
énergétiques sera une question centrale
dans les débats de l'élection
présidentielle et que nécessairement des
décisions majeures seront à prendre dans
les mois qui suivront l'élection
présidentielle c'est une fois espérons
nous sommes à six mois hd vous dites
clairement puisque vous posez le choix
du président monsieur emmanuel macron il
faut avant la livraison de lepers
flamanville il faut y aller il faut
lancer chez nous avons besoin dans
l'élection présidentielle de clarifier
pour le pays qui ont des primes si je
vous réponds je pense que ça ne serait
pas de bonne politique ni de bon aloi de
prendre la décision comme ça tombait du
ciel ex abrupto alors que nous allons
avoir un très grand débat national et
cette question elle doit être posée et
elle doit être résolue par l'élection
présidentielle il n'y a pas de moyen de
conserver une électricité à un prix
abordable qui soit fiable à laquelle on
puisse faire appel qui permettent de
répondre aux l'extension considérable
des besoins d'électricité en mobilité
comme dans la maison ou dans les
voitures beau comme dans la maison s'il
n'y a pas de production d'électricité
répondent et se dire que pour vous
l'échéance présidentielle le président
d'un véritablement cartes sur table dire
ce qu'il veut me gère ses centrales et
des éthers cette question là il y
répondra j'en suis persuadé super l'a
dit hier entre les lignes et il est
nécessaire que nous en assumons les
réponses ce sont de très gros
investissements et ce sont des
investissements qui seuls nous
permettent d'être à la hauteur du défi
climatique qui se posent il n'y a pas
d'autre solution nous allons passer du
défi climatique je vais dire à
l'histoire un peu politique et même
politicienne est ce que vous avez un
quart à 15 que vous le l'assumer un
caractère sanguin françois bayrou un
caractère est jetée rugby arrive vous
allez dire vous entrez dans la mêlée
avec richard ferrand bah oui il ya des
moments où on en rit souvent tous les
deux oui à des moments d'affrontements
dans lesquels les les comment dirais-je
les les habitudes du rugby beuve peut
prendre trouver leur place où et quand
même mais cela donne une image
particulière c'est dans un livre autour
d'emmanuel macro où il les dit à une
passe d'armes zone est quasiment venu
aux mains avec richard ferrand le jour
de l'investiture des manuels m'attends
pas tout à fait c'est à dire que c'est
qui babac à urt moment d'affrontement je
ne crois pas d'ailleurs que richard
ferrand était le seul responsable de ce
moment d'affrontement mais pour moi en
effet c'était un enjeu très important
que de respecter les engagements que
nous avions pris de la place respective
de chacun des deux mouvements dans la
majorité futur je vais avec josé poser
dans l'élection d' emmanuel macron et
vous vous attendiez à ce que cet accord
passé avec les maquereaux ni sur le
nombre de circonscriptions soient
respectés oui alors c'est un peu
difficile à suivre pour eux pour ceux
qui nous écoutent mais oui je suis pour
le respect des engagements
je n'ai que cette ligne là
lorsque l'on tape dans la main chez moi
en tout cas là bas dans les pyrénées là
où on respecte ce genre de tradition
quand on tape dans la main c'est fait
est ce que vous confirmez alors monsieur
bayrou ce qui est écrit dans un livre en
val cité c'est le livre des journalistes
d'avé l'homme le traître est le néant
savoir que les maquereaux nice vous ont
proposé un accord une sorte de
dédommagement car votre parti n'a pas
obtenu le nombre de circonscriptions
parle d'une sorte de roman tout ça c'est
des blacks c'était fade est donc le
il ya eu ce moment de tension autour du
nombre de députés que nous allions avoir
est en effet des mots malheureux ont été
prononcées en disant si vous n'avez pas
le nombre de députés on peut vous
garantir des ressources mais jamais de
notre vie et
c'était marielle de sarnez qui est qui
est partie comme vous savez qui c'est un
proto l'instant bien filmé en première
ligne
et elle a évidemment éclaté de rire
parce que jamais nous n'avons et changer
la représentation politique contre des
ressources fut très intéressant ça vous
a été proposé oui enfin on me dit que là
vous a été proposé ce sont ce sont des
ce sont des pratiques que nous ne
n'avalise ont pas voilà qu'est ce que
vous pensez d'un livre qui est écrit sur
un président emmanuel macron et le titre
est quand même assez éloquent le traître
est le néant que les journalistes n'ont
pas rencontré
alors
il ya plusieurs choses dans la question
ce genre de type c'est fait pour faire
vendre
c'est pas c'est pas fait pour rendre
compte du contenu d'un livre c'est fait
pour faire vendre deuxièmement écrire un
livre sur quelqu'un sans le rencontrer
c'est en effet un peu étrange
troisièmement qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce
livre je suis en valois de traîtrise de
manipulation de petits calculs et on se
dit c'est ça le nouveau monde en le
lisant eh bien le la certitude qui est
la mienne c'est que
la fonction présidentielle est l'homme
qui remplit cette fonction eux ne sont
pas dans les petites manoeuvres ce que
j'ai vu pendant cinq ans alors la jatte
est un pur pour avoir été présent
j'allais dire chaque jour
c'est que jamais les manoeuvres les
petites ruses non occupés la moindre
place dans les décisions d'état qui ont
été prises c'est pour ça que vous
soutiendrez de nouveau le président deby
il se présente évidemment mais vous
comprenez ça le chaque jour un président
de la république il est face à des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux nationaux des
enjeux pour le pays où chaque famille
chaque mère et père de famille et chaque
enfant siens conserver une sympa mais
aussi des batailles il ya ainsi des
calculs politiques voire politicien
c'est la luz et moi je suis en désaccord
avec l'idée selon laquelle
tout serait constamment tiré vers le bas
par
des regards des commentaires des pseudos
décryptage qui permet au goût qui vise à
faire croire que tout est moche ce que
je vois ce que j'ai vu et ce que
j'entends tous les jours c'est que
précisément les décisions sont prises en
fonction d'enjeux qui vont loin qui
porte à l'intérêt du pays des questions
et puis une réaction à ce que l'on vient
d'apprendre que vous le souhaiterez dans
quelques instants monsieur
est ce que vous avez tiré d'ailleurs un
trait définitif sur ce que vous croyez
être votre destin présidentiel je peux
pas j'ai pas posé m je vous sers minerai
définitif je suis je suis parent par
vocation un citoyen qu'est ce que c'est
un site ces quelques tours n'ont pas
entendu c'est à dire que ça m'a
longtemps vous pouvez être encore
candidat aux présidentielles temps des
mois de faux pas sourire dont on peut on
peut poser monsieur très sérieux mais
qu'est ce que c'est un citoyen c'est
quelqu'un qui se sent à chaque instant
responsable à sa place du destin du pays
mais je le suis mais je suis pas
candidat et merveilles aux ébats mais
vous avez un inventeur fort attire plus
que beaucoup d'autres alors il arrive
que cette responsabilité de citoyen vous
conduisent à occuper d'importantes
responsabilités y compris d'opinion et y
compris à vous présenter à des élections
je les fais trois fois et je vais pas
vous dire que j'ai changé dit vous
n'allez pas me dire c'est maintenant que
vous ne serez plus candidat sauter la
porte est toujours ouverte jamais je
vous dirais des choses pareilles c'est
quand même incroyable c'est dire que ce
matin françois bayrou peut être mais
encore candidat à la présidence et
essayons de tellin élite d'être de bon
aloi ensemble
je vous dis que je n'ai jamais renoncer
à aucune de mes responsabilités parce
que c'est ma mission c'est pour ça que
je le
savais quelqu'un d'autre pourrait tenir
le même discours ce matin edouard
philippe qu'est ce que vous pensez de
son initiative de son parti horizon lui
compte peser et votre maison commune
apparemment ils pourraient faire chambre
à part dans votre maison
peut-être y at-il une différence
d'appréciation pour moi par quel wenning
un parti politique c'est un grand
courant profond du pays c'est une
sensibilité c'est une philosophie
et les partis politiques ne se
construisent pas autour d'un destin
individuel c'est ma vision je suis entré
dans le dans le courant politique est le
mien j'avais 20 ans je vous parle des
d'affilée donc j'ai bien saignant en
parlant de lui savonner non mais c'est
pourquoi je dis qu'il peut y avoir des
différences d'appréciation elle s'en
faut un parti politique pour moi ce sont
des solidarités de gens qui pensent la
même chose ça ne sont pas des
solidarités construite autour
seulement d'une personnalité mais c'est
un droit constitutionnel de créer des
partis politiques il est garanti par la
constitution
on est libre de les construire ma vision
à moi je voulais expliquer c'est une
vision plus profondes merci à tous et
qui touche pas
à l'idée qu'on se fait de son avenir qui
touchent à des raisons de vivre pour un
pays c'est pas la même chose et mes
chats goûter la différence bon chacun
est libre et vous l'êtes aussi un de
vous porter de nouveau candidat on a
bien compris ce matin rien n'est jamais
fermée merci françois bayrou merci sonia
maroc